turning now to politics and former
president Donald Trump who is going hard
after Florida Governor Ron DeSantis in
new attacks posted last night the former
president calling his possible 2024
rival quote average and then going on to
attack the governor of Florida's
pandemic response something DeSantis is
really running on DeSantis of course was
a bright spot for republicans in these
midterms winning re-election by a wide
margin we're going to get to that all
that in a moment in more detail but
first we do want to update you on the
status of those outstanding Senate races
everyone's looking for outcomes
Democratic senator Catherine Cortez
masto as of now gaining on Republican
Adam laxalt in Nevada she is just under
9 000 votes behind at this hour while
Senator Mark Kelly also a Democrat over
in Arizona has expanded his lead over
Republican Blake Masters as more ballots
are counted Scott McFarland is following
all of it for us on Capitol Hill and it
is a lot this morning Scott Good morning
Tony good morning to you the new
Congress takes over in less than two
months and even though it's unclear
which party will control either chamber
there's already a behind the scenes
Scramble for power
we got the B Team and it's time to put
the A Team in after a marathon campaign
in which more than a quarter of a
billion dollars was spent good afternoon
Georgia Georgia Democratic senator
Rafael Warnock and his Republican
Challenger Herschel Walker are back on
the campaign Trail we're in overtime
that mean we got a runoff
hey out of the bill for this
I will deal for this
you have to admit
that I did warn y'all that we might be
spending Thanksgiving together
if Democrats can score victories and
Senate races in Nevada and Arizona they
can secure the majority even without
Georgia this morning vote counting
continues in those two close races out
west in Maricopa County Arizona election
officials say they're working around the
clock we will be working Friday we will
be working Saturday and we will be
working Sunday to move through these
ballots votes are also still being
counted in several undecided U.S House
races though President Biden is already
celebrating his parties better than
predicted showing Tuesday was a good day
for America a good day for democracy it
was a strong night for Democrats
CBS News projects the house still leans
toward GOP control in California
Republican Kevin McCarthy has already
announced his bid to be speaker they
don't give gavels out by small medium
and large they just give you the gavel
and we're going to be able to govern and
with what might end up being a very slim
majority in the U.S House McCarthy could
base the challenge of needing support
from nearly every Republican so we'll
see if how much Kevin McCarthy how much
arm twisting or how many favors he has
to do uh to get over the top to get his
speakership
if McCarthy does get the gavel
Republicans have told CBS news they will
focus heavily on investigations into the
Biden Administration and they face this
looming challenge of keeping the
government open providing a government
funding bill with so few areas of
agreement with the Biden Administration
Tony it will be a high wire act for two
years yeah it will be uh Scott I want to
Circle back to the conflict that's
Brewing here really he was filling out
into the open between former president
Donald Trump and Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis the former president unloading
on Ron DeSantis overnight in this long
statement how did that play out Scott
yeah Tony just hammering Ron DeSantis on
social media the former president
accused DeSantis of being disloyal and
of playing games DeSantis won
re-election in a landslide Tuesday and
is considered a possible threat to Trump
as a possible front-runner in 2024
former president hasn't announced he's
running yet but Tony he has promised
this big announcement in four days
yeah it'd be hard for the former
president to claim he's not thinking
about it and possibly worried about it
as well Scott thank you very much